>> Next, we're going to travel by the
internet all the way to Australia and
speak to Grahame Grieve.
Who for many years was chief
technology officer of Castro,
a laboratory information
systems company.
Today, he is a consultant
on interoperability.
His company is called
Health Intersections.
Well, Grahame, I want to thank you
very much for being with us today.
I know it's either early or
late in Australia.
I'm not quite sure which, but can we
begin with your telling us a bit about
your background and what led you
into the world of standards?
>> Initially, I start working
as a laboratory scientist.
After a stint doing that,
I got engaged with a vendor that
was selling information system.
I transferred to working for them.
For a number of years, I worked as
the development leader that vendor and
much of the work that we did at the
vendor, maybe 80 to 90% of the work for
awhile was daily integration
of one kind or another.
I increasingly got involved with
the HL7 side of the integration
with the clinical systems.
And personally, more and more
interested in the standards community.
The community space and that lead me to
become more involved in actual service.
And eventually, I left the vendor and
set myself up as a freelance
consultant contractor doing inter
offerability of various kinds.
>> Well, that's interesting and
it makes sense, because as you and
I both know clinical labs are among
the first entities in healthcare to
adopt standards.
So segueing forward all
the way to March 2011 and
what I view as a famous blog post
entitled The Rise and Fall of HL7,
you said that we can create
complex standards, but
the market would ultimately reject them.
Can you explain what you mean by that?
>> Well, we had spent at that stage,
10 or 15 years creating very
complex standards that set out
to define the nature of reality.
The natural meaning of
clinical information and
pursuit of getting full
control over that complexity.
We had developed ever more
complicated specifications.
The people just couldn't
make them work and
the market had rejected the more
complicated variants of those.
The implementation of it
cost billions of dollars,
national programs that squandered
a great deal of money for
other reasons than that alone,
but definitely for that reason.
Even the simpler ones now that
are going to market are going to have
a very big market backlash,
that's quite evident right now.
And by that, I mean, CDA that,
it's got a real impotence in the market,
but impotence will generate reaction.
And it was clear that we could
continue pushing complicated
specifications, but
ultimately the market would say,
even if you impose this
[INAUDIBLE] government regulation,
we're not going to do it and I just
haven't needed to find a fresh approach.
>> So in that same blog post
that you stated the problem,
you proposed a solution around
JSON Web Services combined with
a simpler data model derived from the
RIM and this is come to be called FHIR.
Can you explain what
FHIR is to the students?
>> So we started by looking and saying,
people out there who are looking out
there and doing interoperability and
getting Getting kudos for
doing it well, how they do it and
the answer was invariably,
restful web services.
It's a mixture of a set of
technologies and a set of paradigms
about how information is exchanged
that make the solution simple,
stable, easy to use and
a whole variety of contexts.
And technically, very scalable.
Also, there is a great deal
of solid collaboration,
frameworks around security and
authentication and so forth,
which have all developed
in support of the web.
FHIR is just taking those
base technologies and
welding those with what we
know about health information.
About getting solid, reliable,
safe exchange of health information and
just combining those two to produce
a easier to use specification for
exchanging healthcare information.
>> Well, to do that FHIR attempts
to define a subset of HL7 RIM
that meets most day to day clinical
needs even for complex patients.
And as I understand it, that's being
defined as standards really should be
through a collaborative process.
Can you explain that process,
how is FHIR actually being
defined at the detail level?
>> Fundamentally it's
a nuturative process.
We have what are called
Domain Committees.
They're gatherings of domain
experts from around the world.
In particular, clinical or business
process specialties within health care.
We work with those
Domain Committees to clarify
the requirements that are common and
shared and
then we draft the standard
based on those requirements.
Then we work with a bunch
of implementation programs,
external programs, vendors and then
we hold connect-a-thons where anyone
can come and try these things out.
I have a bunch of different tryout
programs, where we iterate those to
where we think it's something that we
can actually use in the specification.
Then we as HL7 balance that,
which process where all HL7 members
can vote on the quality of
the standard and ask for changes.
Once that's balanced and then we
publish that as a draft standards,
then the process starts again.
Eventually, in a couple of years time,
we'll push it through to becoming
a full blown normative standard.
But we're not in any hurry,
because we want to really run that
interaction cycle as much as we
can before we give it to normative
standards are not changeable and
everyone's committed to them and
we want to get as much iteration done as
we can before that we get to that point.
>> So, I'm sure that feedback
from actual adopters of FHIR is
important to this process.
How is FHIR option going?
How widely is it being used today and
are you pleased with where we're at?
>> When we first laid out
the project plan for FHIR,
we expected that we would get a little
bit of adoption interest at this phase.
We've just published a first draft,
it's effectively an early beta.
We expected that we'd have a little
bit of engagement with a few users,
particularly in the space of personal
health record access crossing the web,
because the target
technologies batch and
that personal health access, because
it's basically new space and there's not
a lot of established interfaces and
communities and ecosystems.
It's not working out like that,
we're getting a whole lot of
adoption in a whole lot of areas.
Suppose that we can deal with and
it's really ten fold more
adoption than we expected.
We didn't expect that,
just because of the change part that is
an early beater and that all of
the implementors need to accept
that the specification is
still subject to change.
And therefore, the implementations
will have to deal with that.
We didn't expect that to be the case and
it's just that the overall
advantages of FHIR are so
compelling that it's driving
strong adoption now,
rather than having people wait
to see how things developed.
>> Well, I think that you in the FHIR
community are in the right place at
the right time, as adoption of digital
records has grown exponentially at
least here in the United States where
the government is promoting it heavily.
People are beginning to recognize that
with that interoperability, the benefits
of these systems or many of the benefits
won't really be recognized and so
the attention is clearly
turning to interoperability and
people are looking for a workable
solution and there you are with one.
So congratulations, but
one final question.
As you look out a few years, what do
you think we might be with respect
to health data standards, FHIR and
interoperability in general?
>> I think first of all,
that data exchange is not something that
solves any problems and
that's what we're working on.
We're working to make
data exchange cheaper, so
that it becomes just easier to
actually exchange data, but
the start of that comes
nearly from stretching data.
Beyond that, once we can exchange data,
we need to have interoperable workflow,
interoperable paths of care.
Right now, those things can't exist,
because of data
interoperability blocks those.
So, I expect we'll have increasing
focus on clinical interoperability
rather than health information
interoperability and
that will become more and
more evident over the next few years.
Looking past that, I would really
like to see an environment
where healthcare data availability
is no longer the problem.
Right now, it's a big problem for
people within the healthcare process,
the providers of the healthcare and
a big problem for consumers,
although a lot of them aren't
even able to recognize that.
I'd like to take that away, so the
question is no longer data availability,
but what do you do with that?
I think that we'll increasingly
see the adoption of health two,
which people often call patient
centered healthcare that
does depend on facile information.
I think that we will see
aggregation towards a number of
very few providers of very large
healthcare record systems and
a huge differentiation in
the provision of access and
control and
exchange of the information between
the various records on
the very large providers.
And those very large providers
will probably aggregate
out of consortiums of large
healthcare provider networks,
which I forward there and
or national programs and
it'll probably cross
jurisdictional boundaries.
Those are the things that we're
starting to see happen now, but
they are still a long,
long way away from being reality.
>> Well, I think you're absolutely right
on all and I particularly like your
comments earlier on about
the need to develop better and
more standardized clinical processes and
workflows.
That is clearly going to be
the next challenge after we have
sufficiently standardized data.
It's been great chatting with you.
I'm sure the students have gained
a lot from this discussion and
I can only thank you again for
taking the time,
either very early or very late
in your day to be with me today.
Thank you very much.
>> Pleasure.
Thank you.